and another thing about the personality
and charisma you don't need it we just
saw through the latest presidential
election you don't even need a candidate
you need someone in the basement
you don't need anyone out there on the
campaign trail you don't need anyone on
the television you don't need anyone
doing interviews you literally have an
image of someone which they have of
biden so why wouldn't they just repeat
the same thing i mean the media controls
reality for a large swap of people and
that reality was was conveyed the power
of the media was really perfectly
represented through the last election
where a candidate didn't even run hold
on hold on and we have the article from
atlantic stay alive joe biden democrats
need little from the front runner beyond
his corporeal presence
let me let me let's talk about media
rant that's what it was the media ran
for president exactly yeah and the media
one bernie is getting their way bernie
bernie's biggest mistake in 2020
was running as a democrat
he's not a democrat he is an independent
right
the democratic party basically
screwed him over in 2016.
then at one point he's leading into
polls he was leading in the polls he
almost became the president and then
everyone
freaked out the dnc
all the other candidates up on that
stage the media everybody and they went
after him and within two weeks he was
done
as soon as south carolina happened
he should have never
run as a democrat because he ran
independent trump would have won he
keeps he keeps saying he keeps saying i
have we have the largest grassroots
organization
we have the largest grassroots
organization better thank you twenty
dollars
i am asking you again
another great once again asking you to
give all your money to me
he could have bernie sanders he could
have run as a democrat he would have
gotten
he would have gotten a ton of
he basically he could have he could have
actually debated trump and biden
think about how amazing that would have
been he didn't need the democrats but
instead he was just like he and he goes
and i promise that i will uh i i will
get behind uh the nominee he didn't want
to do that he didn't want to get behind
biden but he had to well you know
because he wants to keep his money the
only the only reason that he he became a
he ran as a democrat for a second time
[ __ ] is because
he he wanted that uh he wanted that
national attention to be up on stage
again
but
he didn't have anything new to say
and instead all these other candidates
like uh castro elizabeth warren all
these people they just they just
basically co-opted a whole bunch of his
ideas and he just saturated everything
now bernie isn't like he he wasn't like
a special person everybody in that stage
was was talking about the things that
you know free college and immigration
and all these things and he screwed up
for me he screwed himself over he tried
one up one-upping everyone else being
like remember backward i said we have to
have secure borders i didn't mean it i
am not a bigot we should have completely
opened borders and we can bring in
everybody
i loved it when the world socialist
website called bernie sanders a
nationalist capitalist
no no yeah the world's because he's he
was speaking at a rally and someone said
you know should we allow all the
refugees to come in open the borders and
he went no no heavens no if we open the
borders everyone in the world would want
to come here he talked about it being a
koch brother plan trying to get free
labor inside of the united states to
compete with the american labor force
which again no one even talks about
anymore which is crazy he was making
some good points but i think he played
his role he did i don't think he was an
idiot i think he did exactly what they
told him to do he said yes master tell
me what to do and he did it exactly like
they wanted him to do it
he injected he injected a whole bunch of
energy into the democratic party he got
a whole bunch of money he got a whole
bunch of people young people
predominantly interested in the party
that were never interested some of them
tried to rebel but he came on that
national stage and he bowed down to
hillary he said okay everyone put all of
your power all of your energy everything
you have sacrificed for me give it to
hillary i'll i'll tell you i'll tell you
i remember exactly what happened bernie
sanders was standing before this large
activist base point who was in seattle
who were pointing their lightsaber at
hillary who's on the ground going too
weak
and then bernie was like you don't don't
do it i need her to win i i i need her
and then the people were like no hillary
is wrong and evil and then bernie
sabered off the the populist left's han
the saber and then hillary forced
lightning out the window and then but he
would i thought in power and then he
fell to his knees and hillary clinton
walked over to him and she was like rise
my bernie sanders and bernie was like i
will do whatever you say
and that's how we got darth sanders
i thought you were i'm sorry i thought
you were to you were going to refer to
the seattle
uh rally remember when the black lives
matter
oh yeah
basically just just they just gave up
and started calling the uh wow and
started calling the crowd racist
and
the crowd is like what are you what what
how dare you how dare you bernie bernie
needed the democratic party to lift him
up and i i think genuinely that bernie
was like
i will use the democratic party that's
why he ran as a democrat it was the only
way he was going to get a pedestal and
he had to play ball and that meant he
had to change his positions and he
probably thought but once i'm president
i'll do the right thing and then it's
never going to happen and then once they
made him rich he was like well i i
deserve it i've i've fought my whole
life and so now he's got what how many
houses does a guy own
uh three houses in the summer camp he
said right hey bravo you know being a
socialist pays off i guess i mean for
the wealthy elite ones for the poor
people they tend to starve or die but
you know in this capacity everybody who
voted for these democrats i tell you man
i mentioned this before my friends
people i know my whole life were like
you're so dumb trump's an idiot biden's
the best and now they're going like
my job's going to fire me if i don't get
this vaccine but my doctor's saying like
i should do it what do i do and i'm like
i'm like you're coming to me for advice
now
wow i'm impressed why don't you ask joe
biden why don't you ask him ask him what
he thinks joe biden is gloating that i'm
losing my job
well bend the knee bro you wanted it but
but trump is the fascist oh i remember
when trump deployed the military to deal
with antifa riders burning down
buildings and killing people oh wait he
didn't do that i will i will say though
it was uh i think was it bill barr who
went and killed that got that antifa guy
oh yeah you know what i'm talking about
the guy who shot aaron danielson
barred dispatched feds and they went
found the guy and he was in his car and
said a shootout happened they killed him
hey uh lydia yes
you uh you sent me a link earlier
uh do you want to talk about that real
quick which one is that uh
uh
wisconsin
kenosha
whiskin center right yeah so we were
talking a little bit about wisconsin so
one of the things that comes up that has
come up is that
um kyle i don't want to get us in
trouble but kyle rittenhouse's lawyers
have talked about how he was shouldn't
have been in trouble because he uh he
was following some of the hunting
protocols there in wisconsin
yeah so he was allowed to carry a gun
and everyone's like oh you know humans
aren't animals and it's like well it
matters but also and then jacob blake
yeah
yeah we have this from nbc news
hunting laws allowed kyle rittenhouse to
carry weapon during fatal shootings in
wisconsin lawyers say i mean that's
that's the gist of it lawyers say well
sure sure but i'm pretty sure they're
correct because we've got over this
numerous times about the statutes and
whether you're allowed to carry open or
not and he didn't have a handgun in a
long gun which typically are regulated
less and so i'm pretty sure we had
someone come out i was like no no here's
the statue here's the law and they're
like he was allowed to carry the
weapon see i i i think that they i think
eventually they're going to have a
this this i think they're going to end
up trying to throw it out i think yeah i
think after words there's probably going
to be
like merrick garland will probably come
out and say we need to have a an
investigation like they did with michael
brown and then they'll do it and they
and they won't be able to do anything
about it so initially i was saying i
thought written house will get life but
then the judge seems to have come out
very much like yeah f off to the the s
media when they were like he did the
okay hand gesture a white power hand
gesture and the judge was like what are
you talking about that's not true
he's like i've never heard of that yeah
are you lying to me
and then they were like oh my but the
adl says and he was like i don't know
what you're talking about that's
ridiculous
yeah so then people were like whoa this
judge is like not having it but you're
right i think what'll happen is
now i'm kind of leaning towards kyle
might actually win and then merrick
garland comes in with oh yeah
well well uh what the link that lydia
sent me earlier was that the department
of justice isn't going to charge the
police officer
that shot uh jacob
right as they sh there should never be a
charge jacob blake is the is the rapist
correct no no he's the hero
remember that you know
he's the guy who saw you
in her bed and by abiding
he's the guy he's the guy who sexually
assaulted that woman in her bed yeah and
then when the cop tried to stop him from
escaping and kidnapping some children he
grabbed the knife and then the cop shot
him that that's who we're talking about
right yes the hero the hero yes
i remember a bunch of nfl players put
the that they they put the stickers
saying they supported rape on their on
their helmets
oh my god
that's true
i mean they did technically they did
yeah but but the department of justice
they they know and he even and and i
think the big thing was he was on it was
either robin roberts or gayle king
uh he basically said well yeah i had a
knife and you're just like um that's it
case closed sir
yeah i don't know who these players are
but here's like here's a guy and he's
throwing the ball and he has a sticker
on his helmet that says he supports rape
that's great and then here's uh i think
here's another guy i don't know these
quarterbacks uh stick around there how
much
expressing their support for rape oh all
of these guys wow what team is that new
orleans this one new orleans do new
orleans rapists i guess
it's like i don't i don't i don't know
anything about football to be honest but
uh
you know a bunch of players came out in
support of rape good for them yeah i
guess and and look you know you can come
to me and tell me but tim surely you
must understand they didn't know that
and i'll be like so you mean to tell me
these guys didn't know anything about
what happened in in wisconsin with jacob
blake and they're supporting him anyway
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm not going to
make that assumption because that makes
too many too much of an assumption i'm
gonna go ahead and say they're
supporting jacob blake because they know
the story which means they support rape
and and i'm sure that the same thing
happened with uh the wnba
too weren't they didn't they have like
little you know like
probably jacob lake stickers on there
under five dollar uniforms i really feel
like all of them just heard the story of
this poor prosecuted persecuted oh yeah
they did yeah oh my gosh the wnba
created a shirt with bullets in it in
support of rape good good that's great
good for them i mean in support of a
rapist sorry oh okay
yeah well you know you're right you're
right it was it was it was sexual
assault he sexually assaulted potato
potato
we got to be clear on this because these
are the people that come out and claim
that they fight for women that they
fight women's rights and all of these
these these individuals are calling kyle
rittenhouse a kid or the y a terrorist
for trying to defend his community after
a seven-year-old man was was bashed over
the back of the head and left bloody and
bleeding on the ground by a bunch of
rioters and he put the reason they
attacked him was because he put a fire
out in a dumpster they were pushing
towards a gas station we've had what
four or five witnesses come out with the
show with video evidence proving that
was the case yeah and then he fled when
they attacked him jacob blake went into
a woman's home and assaulted her
sexually and then tried kidnapping her
children and they wear his name and call
kyle written as the terrorist
malcolm x once said the media is the
most powerful entity on earth they have
the power to make the innocent guilty
and to make the guilty innocent and
that's power because they control the
minds of the masses he's correct thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time